Speaker 1: All right, let's get to emails.
The Friday mailbag you can email info at David
Pakman dot com sometimes will include a tweet
or a YouTube comment or whatever.
Today we're starting with a Facebook message
and it is a pretty ugly one.
This one is from James.
James writes, You're a very misinformed moron.
Now your is.
Why?
Oh, you are.
It's almost a requirement if you write Trumpist
hate mail that you use the wrong your.
Okay.
You're a very misinformed moron.
I have never seen Trump shocked about anything
Democrats have tried.
The Democrats are scared of Trump because
they can't control him as they control Biden.
That's because he doesn't want the truth is
their response to a message saying, by the
way, David can't respond to you individually.
This is a really common thing we see for many
of these MAGA people, which is Democrats are
scared of Trump.
The problem with dealing with Democrats are
scared of Trump is, of course, you know and
I know it's not scared of Trump.
It's horrified at what a disaster he is.
And the truth is.
It is scary the things Trump would do if allowed
to do them.
They use the word scared in a very different
way.
They use scared to mean intimidated by just
overwhelmed with Trump's masculinity and intelligence
and drive and all these things that make absolutely
no sense to feel about Donald Trump.
No, we're horrified in the way that you're
scared of really serious illness or a fascist
dictator or, you know, whatever the case may
be.
But of course, good luck explaining that to
them.
And why is it always the wrong your.
Can someone explain to me why that is?
I would love to understand it.
Michael wrote in.
Michael wrote about coverage of the Colorado
shooting and said, Hey, David, I've been a
listener for a while, but I'm curious about
why you haven't covered the Colorado shooting.
I've listened to both Monday and Tuesday shows
following the weekend shooting, and I cannot
recall your coverage of this.
Thanks, Mike.
So there's there's two things going on with
my coverage of shootings, and I'm glad to
sort of change my perspective if it makes
sense to change it.
Number one is there are so many shootings
in the United States and so many of them are
mass shootings and so many of them are happening
in ways that are motivated by the I certain
identity factors, which is sort of what we
call hate crimes.
Right, targeting LGBTQ people or Jewish people
or whatever the case may be that it's sometimes
hard to find something new to say about them
and.
I sometimes feel like I don't have anything
to say about these shootings because they
are so common.
That's one thing.
Second thing is in particular, when there
are some of the really big shootings, they
get a lot of media attention.
A lot of the early information is often wrong.
And with certain breaking stories, you still
report on them early.
Because they are unique stories.
And while, of course, every single one of
the victims of a mass shooting is unique,
we don't go well, there have been other people
killed in mass shootings, so the victims don't
matter.
No, that's not what I'm saying.
But what I am saying is that because the circumstances
repeat themselves time and time again, I find
it less useful to just report what we know
3 hours in or whatever the case may be.
So we ended up talking about the shooting
on Wednesday.
This email came in about Monday, Tuesday.
We talked about the shooting on Wednesday.
That's why I sometimes and deliberately slower
in reporting on some of these mass shootings.
People want them reported on more quickly.
I'm willing to do it.
I just don't know how much I have to add,
particularly when we don't yet have the full
story.
Michael wrote in about evidence based medicine
and says, David, great start to Monday's show,
explaining the risks of cardiac complications
from vaccines compared to risks from COVID.
You explain things clearly, calmly, and with
a high level of expertize.
Thanks.
Sadly, the people who would most benefit from
your charitable sharing either won't understand
it or won't listen.
Yes, that is often the case.
On another note, it is unfortunate you have
to waste your time answering critics on your
show.
But on the other hand, you do acknowledge
your critics, and that is more than HANNITY,
Carlson, Jones, O'Reilly or the others on
the right will do.
Keep up the good work.
It really matters.
Thank you, Michael.
No comment.
Just presented without comment.
Very much.
Appreciate that message.
Teresa wrote in with a request that I've gotten
from many people.
Theresa said, Hey, David, can you give members
access to your soundboard?
Pretty please.
Best Theresa.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Everybody else who makes money to fund themselves
is back.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you all know the soundboard.
So here's the deal with the soundboard.
I would love to set up as a feature for our
members.
That's a great bonus feature, an extra feature,
access to the soundboard that I have here
for the show.
I don't know how to achieve that from a technical
perspective.
I guess we need some kind of a web based soundboard
system that is maybe password protected or
unlisted in some way.
So here's my thought.
If anybody out there knows how I can do what
Theresa is asking, which is make access to
my soundboard a premium member feature.
If you can tell me how to do it, I will do
it.
And I think that that would be a really cool
thing to be able to offer.
Melissa wrote in about YouTube and Melissa
says, We watch your program every night in
our home.
Well, thank you, Melissa.
Melissa adds, I've blocked out when you talk
about subscribing to your YouTube channel
only because we don't watch you on YouTube.
We watch your program on Free Speech TV.
I have since come to my senses and subscribed.
Thank you for all the work you and your team
do to keep us informed.
Melissa from Wisconsin.
Thank you, Melissa.
Yeah, listen, even if you watch on another
platform, if you want to do us a very small
and completely free favor, if you have any
kind of account with Google, YouTube, etc.,
subscribe to the channel.
It really helps us.
We're working to 2 million subscribers.
You go to YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show quick, easy and very important.
Justin wrote in about this idea of executing
drug dealers that some in the MAGA right,
including the failed former President Donald
Trump, have started fixating on.
Justin writes, I find it interesting Trump
is saying all convicted drug dealers should
be executed and not specifying what drugs
you need to be caught dealing or trafficking
in order to get executed.
Is he saying people convicted of dealing cannabis
should be executed?
Serious question.
I think he is saying that, quite frankly.
I think he is saying that because he's not
making any distinction.
And I mean, listen, I guess we have to ask
him.
It's often very hard to know what it is exactly
that Trump is suggesting, but he doesn't seem
to be making any distinction.
As far as which drugs the dealing of should
get you executed.
But the most important thing is it's completely
hypocritical because remember that even though
Donald Trump is now saying drug dealers are
such a scourge or scorch, as he used to say
during the COVID era, that they should be
killed, he also pardoned a bunch of drug dealers
on his way out of office.
So maybe not a shock to some of you that he's
a bit of a hypocrite.
Okay.
Last thing Dylan wrote to me, a message called
On Judgment and tells me that in the following
text he will attempt to explain the principle
of non judgment and why he believes it to
be a just tenet on which to base our relations
with others.
He then sent pages and pages of all sorts
of biblical talk that is so long winded that
I couldn't even fit it on the screen.
Do not send me this stuff.
It is not being read by anybody.
We have a message on our website, on the contact
page which says Email in your message will
be read.
But me, David, I can't necessarily read every
email and I certainly can't respond to them,
but someone's going to read it.
No one is reading this stuff, Dylan.
No one is reading the pages and pages of biblical
mumbo jumbo about non judgment.
It's just not getting read.
It's not relevant to the show.
Please, please, please, just don't bother
because you're wasting your time.
And now you've wasted my time and the audience's
time with me explaining.
That it's not going to be dealt with.
Okay.
So please no more other emails info at David
Pakman dot com.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join pacman dot com, get instant
access and of course the coupon code 24 starts
now is available.
Also, the free whitepaper on Arguing Politics
and Changing Minds is available at David Pakman
dot com slash guide.
I will update you next week on the number
of downloads, but I am quite ready to call
it a success.